Yeah!
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Blueprint Tycoon.
Now this is a resource management kinda base-building style game.
And its hard to describe because it's very simplified from everything
so I started the tutorial but I'm gonna walk you guys through it
HOWDY!!!
We've been given these islands and tasked with settin' up a settlement to gather and profit from their natural resources
Cause whenever you come to new land, you want to exploit absolutely everything you can for profit.
As your assistant, I will guide you on to building a
successful, efficient, and profitable settlement
Workers are the foundation of any enterprise
Let's hire some by building houses.
let's hire some by building houses
because the only way to get new people
Because the only way to get new people
is to build houses and they
automatically come with
Is to build houses, and they automatically come with.
So
so you press hard to rotate you do the
thing with the thing in the thing in the
You press R to rotate,
You do the thing with the thing and the thing and thi-
things do like that and then that and
then he got two houses your blimps come
*jibberish*
Like
That
an then that.
then you got two houses,
your blimps come over,
over and then they start construction
somehow and then you cancel bill mode
and they start construction somehow.
and than you cancel build mode and you need to build a marketplace.
and you need to build a marketplace so
the marketplace
So,
The marketplace...
god dammit this music is too cheerful
GOD DAMMIT this music is too cheerful!
oh jesus you stopped sorry that was like
I don't know what it was but that was
Oh jeez, it just stopped.
Sorry that was like...
I don't know what it was, but that was like,
destroying my brain.
Okay, this is much better.
okay, this is much better.
so we need to build a marketplace to be
able to provide our workers with the
provide our workers with the appropriate sustenance for foods.
We need to build a marketplace to be able to
provide our workers with the appropriate
appropriate sustenance for foods so with
the marketplace you want to build it
sustenance for food.
But you also need to build roads,
You wanna build it...
I don't know kinda close maybe I'm not a
hundred percent sure what but you also
I dunno, kind of close, maybe?
I'm not 100% sure what. (Great tutorial Mark! -_-)
But you also need to build roads
Which is handy, I suppose, for whatever you're trying to do.
But also, you need to provide the marketplace with fresh food,
to be able to do that.
So,
Like this...
Oh, I can actually
to the workers' houses
houses so that they can live which is
handy i suppose for whatever you're
So that they can live!
Now, the cool thing about this game and what makes it really interesting is that
It's all... on this blueprint grid.
And it doesn't get any more detailed than this.
It is basically...
narrowed down to just the gameplay,
So
kinda neat.
And then, when you build your things,
Oh I can actually
these things don't navigate by themselves.
You need to coordinate everything,
and then build a ROAD
WAY more complicated as you go down the road-
And it just told me there were no routes, I-I know
I'm aware.
Okay, so once you do that, you need to left click,
get a vegetable to go over there,
and it doesn't get any more detailed than this
it is basically...
Oh, I gotta follow the tutorial! It's- I'm sorry!
I know what I'm doing BAM just like that.
and then you got your...vegetables
being delivered from what I can only
assume our "farms" to there...
Everything is moving freely.
Okay, this is where I didn't get the
tutorials, so this is new to both you and me.
"Building materials..." oh, *shakes head* "Buildings
require materials to be built."
"Build a wood harvester near the construction; it
doesn't have to be linked to houses."
YOU GOT IT, BABY!
So, it doesn't need to be connected to houses.
Kind of in a line.
Maybe? This is probably a bad place to put it but, mmkay.
So we need to make the tool.
Am I already on the-
EUGHH
So... "Select from "building", the wood
harvester, to the construction."
Okay! Well, that was easy.
You got it, baby!
"Build four more work grounds, and remember to connect them to the marketplace, so the workers can eat their food."
"You can speed up time."
blah blah blah
HA-BOINK
There we go.
There you go. Now we can get some researchers.
"Build two researchers' houses with roads connecting to the marketplace."
Well, shiet.
Okay, so we need to build researchers' houses, because apparently,
They're better! And they live in a higher-class society
than simple, menial workers, apparently.
It sounds like we need someone to overthrow the government already,
but that's besides the point. Okay.
So, you're kind-of getting the basic principle of
you got a baby we're going to get wood up in this honker. So it doesn't need to
be connected to houses so that means
that i can just put them kind of in a
line
maybe this is probably a bad place to
put it but ok now we need to set up a
route so we need to make the tool drag
route tool set up for work
am I already on the Oh God
huh Oh over here okay I got it
so select from building the wood
harvester to the construction
okay well that was easy add some roads and
watch as goods are harvested and ready to
be delivered
you got it baby boink and just like that
we've got wood going into the
construction site build for more grounds
and remember to connect them to the
marketplace of the working of their food
you can speed up time
blah blah blah i'm an expert at this
already you don't need to worry about me
ha boinc cobblesky ha Barsky about how
long ski
there we go and I about bubble
there you go now we can get some
researchers build two researchers houses
with roads connecting to the marketplace
well ship I didn't know that we're gonna
need all that
okay so we need to build researchers
houses because apparently they're better
and they live in a higher class society
than simple menial workers Burnley
sounds like we need someone to overthrow
the government already but that's
besides the point okay so on a slot them
in just here and they just need to
connect to the marketplace so you're
kind of getting the basic principle of
everything here you all shit oh shit
how do i how do i get rid of that bar
god this oh thank goodness my perfect
order is not going to be perturbed
these researchers want some apples well
guess I said what the researchers one
we're trying to get by with good
vegetables are we going to survive one
route
god damn it but you're needy bastards
her I fine we'll do it your way
sac a shit build a road going from there
and then i'll build a round I know what
I'm doing
if that to their apples get that to rush
it
get that - there ma'am so we got our
routes
the apples are being delivered
the apples will be delivered from there
to the researcher houses and then
hopefully
oh we build a lab okay can do building a
lab where do i do this
her I I suppose this doesn't need to be
established anywhere near anywhere else
hopefully so I could just put it right
here along the roadside and husky lab
allows us to research new tech to craft
better more valuable goods
yeah so that we can sell it and make a
profit because that's the only thing
that I care about is this affecting me
I'm gonna I'm gonna do this real quick
link
ok doesn't that look lovely click on the
lab
you got a boss pic research you got a
boss here - I don't know what that means
we require red vials to complete this
research build a red file crafter near
the lab
how many things am I gonna craft holy ok
anyway
link and I guess we're going to put this
right why does it have an input and an
output
yeah I don't like to look at that point
red balls are made with wooden stone
build wooden stone harvesters shed
routes up to the red ball crafter and
watch red bow grafted okay . and i'm
assuming that I got to connect around
the back way so let's just do that . and
i can slot something else up there so I
need stone harvesters and I can do that
try was just one first . and then we got
that and do i need to do
yeah I need to set up routes we need
this to go there
new route and then we need this to go
there
you're out and then we got wooden stone
being delivered easy peasy lemon squeeze
me and everything is good
yeah all wait this one doesn't have a
route I need to get this to their yeah
okay got it
now that we have some red vials let's
use them in lab we're making science
it's a beautiful thing okay so we need
red vials used to the lab
so we need the loo boink
ok the lab is working let's wait for
research to finish you can speed up time
with the bottom of the top bar
all right look at that
and this is just the beginning of this
game i saw a trailer for this game
the ending was just a sprawling
smorgasbord of an island filled with
nothing but crafting and researching and
a whole bunch of cool stuff going on so
there's a lot of potential in this game
I just don't know how to do it yet are
we doing it how do i know all we did it
here to unlocked
I don't know what that means here to
building materials in this case iron
ingots
oh god how do I know how to build then
build a coal harvester next to the iron
harvester and set up around to deliver
cold of the storage
oh ok I don't have
ok kool whoa Oh calm down there whoa get
all jiggly with it
I put that there whoa whoa I didn't even
see that colonize I'm gonna do that
I didn't even know I had this over here
oh that's for making minds
ok we need iron ore we need whoa
no fertility here no fertility
why do we need why do any people banging
but to be able to get iron out the
ground is it joking there about
something getting hard but i'm not i'm
not having none of that is that is
horrible
ok I can do that is apparently there's
fertility of there and I I ruined my
chances at having more iron
they build a core harvester set up
around to deliver to the storage can do
all
yeah I can do that ok route storage iron
ore
k route storage kool got it
okay so that should be good question
now we have the base materials for
crafting ironing its building iron ingot
crafter
good God endless amounts of craftivity
the man ok so that means new ship
I shouldn't have built it so dense in
here it's getting problematic
I don't know if people would be able to
go through one building to get to
another building that makes sense right
people could cut through the market and
then be able to get where they need to
go right ?
so if I build this here and then I build
this here and this here then we have
something going on and I can set up
around from the storage to the earning
it crafter bank
ok that's good right my hopes up but
better because it because if it's not
good
whoa oh I didn't even see that
well what is going on in there why does
that look like crying child from five
nights at Freddy's oh god what have I
done
what was happening we are glad that's so
weird
so cool I don't know what's going on but
I think you owe produce waste which
needs to be properly disposed of
come on so many requirements how is
anyone supposed to keep track of all
this bullshit a waste disposal set up
around from the ironing and crafters to
the waste disposal
well okay waste disposal
shit man what the hell
all right we're gonna do this like this
because I'm I may have made an error
so we got that now that can go there and
then the waste disposal be there
set up a round of betting how about oma
go the ways to there
all right and now set up around to
deliver ironing it's to construction now
goddammit why's it gotta be so how's it
going to be so much game link dooby doo
doo
yeah all right so we got bad for doing
I think who knows really
all right great job the ironing and
supply chain is fully functional
you've learned how to hire workers and
fulfill their needs set up rats research
new tech and new goods times while
disposing of voiced next will learn how
to create our own blueprints to maximize
efficiency
click Next to continue to the next
scenario good God
in this scenario we learned how to make
our own highly efficient blueprints
why try to gather or and crafts in the
gold ingots and then we can look what
build a gold are harvester in the
highlighted selection oh my god
ok how about I took it into the corner
that seems you are fishing I don't know
man I don't know
ah yeah artisan crafter the car mover
for vehicle new blueprint
what what is this always this what was
going on in the middle of the box
holy shit oh man
k goal is to gather the goods and drop
them in the output you can drag windows
around by holding the left mouse button
on the window tile
ok on the right side you can see the
blueprint map and on the left side you
can see the workers and tools you have
available
this is a blueprint we're going to make
the workers will grab the goods grab
them move them to the output and drop
them
first we need to equip the worker in the
harvest so we can use to gather action
ok workers move one square root of time
so let's change the starting position on
the lower left of a better place
oh my goodness Oh grab so we want to
grab that dough gather sorry gather item
will be spawned in that location's like
to grab action so this worker grabs the
item when it's spawned grab
output drop oh oh no oh no oh my brain
is gonna explode
oh my god do I have to do that for all
the buildings
oh god I didn't want this much
micromanagement man who's gonna take me
forever to properly learned learned
digiti ok so we put this here
let's rotate it like this so we got an
input and an output
ok so select the gold new blueprint oh
god what am I looking at this is a
crafter boot for you have input welds
craft outputs and final output
the goal is to grab the good from the
inputs drop them in the welds and use a
worker to weld them together when all
the kids were out of the craft & boos
bond would predict about my guide
what stuff Rick holy bleep boop
yeah on the movement we have two
available workers on the welder and car
tools will have green worker grab the
goods and positioned on the welds the
blue worker will weld them together and
carry the craft and golden get to the
output equip the card on the green
worker the card allows the worker to
carry up to three goods ok
three guards select the start position
start select the services and grab grab
grab
so we got three of them because we got
the cart I get that move to the first
goal drop move drop move drop so we
grabbed three we drop three
now we need to set up the welder so the
blue worker and there's a green worker
in the blue worker
so we need to set up the welder start
that from here we need to weld left
well down to weld it into one ingot and
then grab the final product that will be
made once you well those together and
then drop it in the output section
oh I got it
save the blue friend wow your workers
are currently idol because the building
is none of the input materials set up a
workaround from the gold harvester to
the Inga cracker
I had a set of the road first Jesus man
these guys do now
not make it easy for me so I'm going to
do for now just do that
oh well
woof woof
but you can see the thing that i did
that's what we were looking at before in
that square is exactly every step that I
made so not only are we building on a
macro scale out here on this island not
only are we doing that but also deep
down inside it
there's an even smaller grid we're
crafting is being done so you can see
how the simplicity of this is masked by
the sheer complexity of its intricacies
of its inner workings of its inner
machinations so
Wow holy crap time to make some money
okay this is going to be finally the
reward for all this bullshit workers
need to be paid or they will become
unhappy
yeah or starve to death you know one of
the other
ok contracts right now the only contract
available as a stone contract which pays
11 per item
grab the stone contract okay 15 goods
heard a salesmen stone by building a
stone officer with the workaround to the
delivery storage you got it so stone
harvester and delivery storage i can do
that
easy peasy stone harvester will build it
right here on jaw and then we need to
roll it up roll it up and then we can
make routes . and then boink
okay so we got stone going there what do
we have
oh we're on the same place that we were
before I'll handy that it made it
exactly the way I made it home
how cool okay well some stone ok so
speed of time building the harvester
wait what has no all we need to make a
blueprint in it
default blueprint ok the blueprints
already there we just need to make it
okay got it got it got it ok so now it's
being done i forgot that it actually
needed to blueprint but the one in here
is not too complicated because it was
just gather and then deposit so well
congratulations you just made some money
cool all right but it seems like our
money is decreasing up
I don't like the sound of that there is
more profitable contract now available
for gold ingots buildings are already
being crafted and sent to the port we
need some way of moving them to the
delivery storage
that's where ships come in airships
transport large quantities of goods in
between starts and supports their ships
are built in your main building selected
now this is the main building where you
can build their ships trading ships and
tokens
click the airship button to queue up
construction you got it baby will do the
default blueprint . i don't want to set
up a new blueprint for that that would
take too long and I my brain would
explode halfway through my brain is
exploded like three times already but
we're getting there getting there
okay next wait for the airship to finish
construction whenever it's done doing
that
remember you can speed up time baba week
and bam ok so it's done the airship is
built now let's build a trading route to
support airship activate new route we're
taking gold from the port and setting it
to delivery storage and we need to pick
golden gates as our thing so if that was
complicated
we just picked the airship and we
created a new route inside of the
airship from the port to delivery
storage and we have to select that
so now it's done now it's gonna go open
the contract windows which is down here
select gold bada-bing can deliver 15
goods per day gold pays better so tried
to deliver all that
so we're going to decrease stone
increase gold
I guess we can just max out gold but i
don't know how many gold we can produce
when I guess 10
all right that Lou . top right you can
see current active nice if not enough
good to present the delivery storage
workers will become idol and I would
hope that they would default this stone
as well
you have idle workers you will see a
message the amount of mist income due to
not having enough goods balance your
contract amount to maximize profits
winter
ok so you do have to balance it all
right we already researched here - we
can upgrade our buildings crafts and
green tokens in the main building
you're gonna have a baby main green I
don't know what these are
let's see what the ya can't even do that
okay got it
we're building whatever the hell green
tokens are they look like green bitcoins
but I don't know if that's going to help
us . all right
the Golden Gate craft is not producing
as much as it could because it does not
have enough gold or upgrading the gold
or harvester to increase the speed of
the blueprint
ok you got a gold or harvester slow down
time a little bit
upgrade wait no we don't have enough
green
well there we go I wasn't there before i
thought i already made that but
apparently not
see all right
great now the harvester more workers
will provide them with a little blah
older brother Bobby . they upgrade the
worker out select the gold or for his
service teacher
upgrade the working around how do I do
that
oh add worker
yeah is that what I wanted I think so
what oh my god oh here
ok that was confusing here to work
around to move faster and carry up to
two goods at once
look at that a new mission has been
added to the contracts missions are
special limited contracts that must be
fulfilled the mission is asking us to
supply 20 micro chips but I don't know
how to do that
topper and sand but there's no fertility
on the island
oh we get to call an eyes wow wow wow
ok so that I had to wrap my head around
real quick but we're going to colonize
it we got a port
when you callin is your first time you
get a free ship which is awfully nice
thank you for that Island has great
fertility for copper and sands which are
two goods and need to craft micro chips
ok I have a feeling we're gonna need
more airships aren't we all just build
two and have them ready to build a
copper harvester and ass and harvester
you got a baby
oh that's very fertile I don't like
saying that not enough workers
shit we gotta build them over here I'm
not building over there fuck that I'm
building over here where I don't have to
worry about shit
all right howling howling and howling
why not why not another up here Punk
ok happy to help have it out hope
okay we got more workers and hopefully
they're gonna cross the sea and actually
go where I need them but who knows they
might be lazy
okay we got that ok we can need copper
08 / laptop and destroyed that one okay
we're just gonna do - we're going to do
to do is good enough for me to get these
to the port
boink ok all right then we need crafters
for microchip so I guess we can put them
right here
can't we make sense right this goes here
this comes here this is here this goes
here they all go there and then the road
connects back to the other side
ok now you have all the necessary boom
stuff so we need to do default blueprint
because I'm not doing that
default yeah I guess when you put a
default blueprinted just applies it to
everything across the board so hopefully
when that happens it will be done
maybe I can upgrade these yes i can
upgrade
nice so i suppose i could just keep
building these which would be nice day
microbes are being produced and the
delivery start and complete the mission
ok so delivery storage over there
shit so go there and then port to port
oh come on use a ship to transport a new
route from there to there
give me microchips and then . okay hurry
up u-boat bastard
we got microchip's to deliver and then
we can do this from here to there
no goods autofill possible open a new
okay we just gotta do this manually then
and then micro chips over there and
everything is hunky-dory on the island
were doing great work all the workers
are doing what they need to do to work
we got upgrades across the board were
building lots of coinage
we need more wood but I'm not worried
about that that's like a later problem
to have
you have a lot of waste so but i'm not
worried about that either shit we need
to take care of the trash problem
fuck okay so I need added this one's
route and it route to also bring the
waist over there we go
ok got it man microchips so no doubt how
to ski
so that's doing that let me get this
other one doing it as well as that would
be handy dandy
butter butter butter boo banga
up baby oh the transports can carry all
of them
I didn't know that if I'd known that I
wouldn't have done that so much
all right move faster baby we got stuff
to do
hopefully we can now it's pretty much it
I don't know what we're going to do with
all the garbage but I need someone to do
that
we only need one of these at a route
let's see clear out
go from port to use airships and shit
move move trash here remove trash here
that's good I don't know it's getting
out fine so long as microchips are
And then you can make another one...like that.
And then immediately, the food goes to the workers' houses;
We're going to get wood up in this honker!
So that means that I can just put them...
[high-pitched] Alrighty...?
Now we need to set up a route.
"Drag route tool. Set up a wor-"
O-oh God.
OH, over here. Okay, I got it
"Add some roads and watch as goods are harvested and ready to be delivered."
BOINK
And, just like that, we've got wood going into the construction site.
I'm an expert at this already. You don't need to worry about me.
HA-BOOSKI
HA-BORSKI
HA-BONK
Long ago, the four Ha-nations lived together in Ha-harmony. Then, everything changed when the Ha-Borski Nation attacked. Only the Ha-Avatar, master of all four Ha-elements, could Ha-stop them, but when the world needed him most, he Ha-vanished. A hundred years passed, and my Ha-brother and I discovered the new Ha-Avatar, a Ha-Bonk Bender named Ha-Mark. And although his Ha-Bonk bending skills are great, he has a lot to Ha-learn before he's ready to Ha-save anyone. But I believe Ha-Mark can save the world.
EUGH, HA-BONSKI
A-and... FLABAPBABOOP
I didn't know that we were gonna need all of that.
So, I'mma, slot them in just...here, and they just need to connect to the marketplace.
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
bye-bye!
*Outro Music*